Рінат Кузьмін одіозний заступник не менш
одіозного пана пшонки в 2014 році проти
цього зрадника було порушено кримінальну
справу Але на жаль він втік її не довели
до кінця а в 19-му тріумфальну за ручку
завели до сесійної зали України більше
того Ринат Кузьмін настільки потрібен
монобільшості що його ввели в ТСК по
вагнерівцями Де цей зрадник колаборант
людина з російським паспортом отримала
абсолютно офіційно підпис доступ до всіх
закритих секретних матеріалів про
найбільш важливо і найкращу спецоперацію
українських спецслужб ви запитуєте про
те А звідки у Москві інформація про всі
наші спецслужби так в Кузьміна він
передав її через тих людей які в цій
залі дали дозвіл який через СБУ дали
дозвіл і в одне питання А ми точно
впевнені що зараз ми добрими робимо дуже
таку Одну хорошу справу тільки
позбавляючи зрадників українського
мандату і дозволяючи їм зараз дуже
комфортно себе почувати в Москві а хто
відповість за те що люди з російським
паспортом зайшли в цю залу щоб були
закриті проти них кримінальні справи Що
за оцими паскими Кузьміна відкривалися
кримінальні справи в тому числі проти
європейської солідарності під ваше у
люлюкання під вашу радість Де сьогодні
звіт пана баканова якого звільнили теж
за по суті дуже серйозні речі Чим
прославився Кузьмін окрім зради тим що
він гарно грав Мурку так от Наша задача
щоб він грав Мурку на нарах а не на
рубльовке і тому сьогодні голосуючи за
те що він має позбутися мандата маємо
дуже голосно у Влада спитати а
відповідати вони будуть перед
українським законом справедливість
вимагає відповіда І до речі Волошин
також має здати мандат його немає тут 10
років